you have spoken out as well about people
being falsely accused of sexual assault
yeah Anne Assange is someone who has
been for years now living basically in a
health arrest situation do you believe
that he's been falsely accused well it's
a case of condom or no condom it was a
consensual relationship that was
happened before and after the situation
that she just wanted to get tested and
that they put aside this whole thing and
you're always innocent before proven
guilty strong views on Assange his
current situation the exiled WikiLeaks
founder has been seeking refuge at the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London since 2012
in a bid to avoid extradition to Sweden
on rape allegations in a newly posted
home on her website titled I like how
you resist me the star discusses her
special relationship with Asajj then
mentions u.s. president Trump and
British prime minister Teresa Mae's
relationship writing it is a romantic
struggle things that the USA and UK
bring to the relationship are bad
secrecy laws keeping julian illegally
detained hating transparency and bombing
countries let's talk a little bit about
your work with Julian there was of
course a lot of media attention having
you spending time with him some probably
not the kind of attention you'd prefer
typing let's talk about what you're
actually working on together why my I
just support him I believe in his
message and he's trying to free the
world by educating it I think it's a
romantic struggle this is such a kind
central person
he's just genius and he's ruffled a lot
of very powerful feathers and so of
course they're going to go after him
obviously he touched on something that's
real we all deserve you know what's
going on the government that we elect
pam has been photographed visiting
Assange at the Embassy on several
occasions and while she won't confirm or
deny rumors that the two are actually
dating BAM has nothing but respect for
them they just excuse his name and got
it was a way to extract Sweden to
extradite him to America where they're
building a case against him would she be
unfairly treated at and as you can see
they just want him dropped because he's
revealing a lot of information that we
need to know Pam was reportedly
introduced to Assange by her good friend
Vivian Westwood who has started an
initiative to save the Arctic he uses
everything he does sick Dan attention
for the
and she feels like I do the same thing
so we're kind of kindred spirits that
way
you have obviously some very very
intense views and many many passions
just from one human to another how do
you keep it all straight
well it's authentic so it's not
difficult it's coming from the heart and
everything I learned I applied for my
life and my foundation